[Music]
so here at the uh the Pete home show we
love video games and we wanted to shine
a spotlight on some of our favorite
lesser known video games because I don't
know if you guys know this here at the
show we do have access to all the
[Applause]
[Music]
games let's do some fake video
games uh first we have Guitar Hero
downstairs neighbor Edition
that's that's fun you have to hit the
different color with the room how you
how you win finally a game for older
people it's going to be great uh next we
have Angry Birds Hitchcock Edition
that's
fun no they've had it up to here with
you you know just catapulting them into
blocks and green didn't need the
tag didn't need the tag tag is the
second part of the didn't
need the explanation of what a tag is
edit all of this
out uh next we got double dragon yeah
they're uh
[Applause]
that's aren't they brothers that's
not that's not okay uh Napa Valley wine
tasting 2K14 is an
exciting yeah that's going to be a good
one there's a code to unlock all the
bordeau uh next up we got Big Buck
Hunter off seon just polishing my guns
and spending time with M
dog
he's thinking about making his own
bomb uh next up super Cohen Brothers
that's a fun
one the the the the princess kidnapped
herself
man deep cut deep cut deep Jeff Bridges
I hope you're watching cuz you're the
only one that's going to get that joke
Street Fighter 2 no Blanca Edition um
he's a monster what what is he doing
there in a tournament for men and women
there's just an electricity monster
that's
like can beat it you
cheater and finally in the Lego Family
of games we have Lego requium for a
dream oh my
God oh
my I'll never do Lego heroin again
[Music]